all right good morning Edna
I'm opening the public hearing on House
Bill 33 and I call Representative
Levesque
okay always right representative
good morning my name is Cassandra
Levesque and I represent Stratford for
Stratford and Barrington
hb33 is about raising awareness for
polycystic ovary syndrome also known as
PCOS
it is a hormonal condition that can be
treated with medication PCOS is
different for everyone the most common
factor leading to a diagnosis is an
irregular period
it affects 1 in 10 women more than 5
million women may be affected in the U.S
alone
it can occur in girls as young as 11
years old
and the exact cause of PCOS is unclear
there's a set of tests that can be done
to determine if you have PCOS every
woman that I have talked to that is
living with PCOS
they all experience different effects
for some it can be very painful for
others they may go without their period
for months or others have not had their
period at all
I'm living with polycystic ovary
syndrome and even though I am being
treated with medication it is still
excruciatingly painful
awareness of PCOS can help so many women
and girls to know about the effects and
as a society we can dedicate more effort
to advocacy education
and research
some of the complications of polycystic
ovary syndrome are infertility
gestational diabetes or pregnancy
induced high blood pressure
miscarriage or premature birth
non-alcoholic
excuse me on this word I've had a
trouble with it uh
stieto hepatitis
metabolic syndrome
type 2 diabetes or pre-diabetes
sleep apnea depression anxiety and
eating disorders
and cancer of the uterine lining
when I bring this up to other women many
do not know what it is and some may not
realize they have it
I definitely did not know what it was
until my doctor discussed it with me
it affects everyone differently and just
having this discussion is important
despite the prevalence of the complex
chronic condition one-third of women
diagnosed with PCOS saw at least three
Health Care Professionals over the
course of two years
before receiving a diagnosis according
to a study from the Perlman school of
medicine at the University of
Pennsylvania
women with PCOS have greater chances of
developing several serious health
conditions including life-threatening
diseases
the risk of a heart attack is four to
seven times higher than women with PCOS
than women of the same age without PCOS
women with PCOS are at greater risk of
having high blood pressure
women with PCOS have high levels of LDL
cholesterol and low levels of HDL
cholesterol
maybe today maybe tomorrow there may be
a girl who is wondering why her period
seems so different than her friends or a
woman who may be wondering why she
hasn't gotten her period
educating and talking about this can
help women go from risking their health
over medicating over the counter with
other the counter medication to help
symptoms or being told this is just
normal too this is an unknown condition
and I can help and will I can and will
help you
I'm requesting you help me and having
New Hampshire join other states in the
education of girls women and health care
providers
so we can get these patients the
information and care that they need
thank you
thank you are there any questions
representative blackis thank you
um so if I understand correctly your
main goal is to
make potential sufferers of this aware
that the the issue exists so they can
try and get proper treatment is that
correct yes and follow-up follow-up
um do not primary care doctors and other
doctors are they not aware of it and if
somebody comes in with problems is this
something they don't diagnose for some
reason
uh some of the women that have gotten
diagnosed they go in at an early age
with their pediatrician sometimes and
the pediatrician just chocks it up to
their period right going and them out
when they're younger
or some doctors they stand with the old
practice of
just try something new take a bath
um
uh Dyer hair or just
take some Midol it'll be fine it's just
your period when in fact it could be
something serious okay thank you
any other questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill 33.
foreign
seeing none I'll close the public
hearing
and
representative blackis
um thank you I'd like to make a motion
of uh in expedient to legislate and uh
all right is there a second
oh second okay okay would you like to
speak to your about I would and um I
feel kind of bad about this hey may I
just ask a question is it important to
um
declare that we're having an executive
session or not
I don't know
I think I think we have to declare okay
fine declare that we are we are going
into executive session
without objection
thank you representative blackis I make
the motion uh in expedient to legislate
on House Bill 33. and now second
I do and uh I want to explain why I'm
doing this
um the issue is I think getting
something
um you know adding another of the I
think there's over 28 of these in there
is not an effective way to raise
awareness is my concern because
basically what happens is on the the
particular day the governors
um staff prepares this
Proclamation and he signs it and there's
probably a press release and that's
generally it
and if you go around and look at the
whole list of them and you talk to
people in the state most people have no
idea that any of these things exist and
so it's really not effective and I think
you know a more effective way of
raising awareness is having people you
know put together an event you know have
a uh you know talk to the Press get a
press conference maybe get information
out to medical professionals maybe get
information out you know posted or
something in the schools and if you want
official recognition if you get a
petition from some people asking the
governor to make a proclamation he's
almost certainly going to do it
but it's it's you know a Grassroots
effort by some group of people to try
and raise awareness
and um
is is more effective and I think the
greatest risk of putting observances in
statute is that you know once the people
are concerned about the issue get a bill
through they think they're done they've
accomplished something but really
they've accomplished nothing effective
to raise awareness and you know I'm
concerned that you know this is a
problem and and people do need to be
aware about it especially the people
that are you know are vulnerable or
might have it and I just don't think
this will work and you know this is
nothing against this particular issue I
I take that position on all the special
days pretty much
thank you representative
thank you as a committee we have seen
these special day
nominations we see them every year and
for the reasons that representative
Lucas explained we have
been
um very hard-pressed to pass them
however we don't want the sponsor of the
bill or the public to think that we
don't care about these issues and that
they're not important
and walking into
um
the lob today had a conversation with
some of the members of my committee
and a sponsor of one of these bills
today
trying to figure out a way to really
make these this event or these events
that people care about significant
and if you can help with that I'd love
to hear from you because I think that
it's something that we as a body
um
can help
and I thank you for submitting the bill
and that wrapped up my comments okay
does anyone else have comments
questions
I'd like to say that from the testimony
it sounded like the more effective way
to increase awareness would be to Lobby
the Board of Medicine to include more
training on this for their members
particularly for pediatricians and
primary care doctors that don't
specialize in reproductive systems
because that might be the most effective
place to make a change and I would hope
that that would be something you would
consider or the sponsors would consider
anyone else representative grotta
and I'm going to offer my help if you
want to do that okay
all right so any further discussion
seeing none
the motion is in expedient to legislate
by lackas seconded by grotta and the
clerk can call the roll
the committee will have to be uh
gracious with our clerk who is
on the first day
absolutely oh Madam chair I would also
say representative remind the new
members that before they answer they
should hit their buttons so that we can
hear them ah yes thank you
I forgot to mention that yesterday but
yes we are being recorded and live
streamed and if your button is not on we
may be able to hear you but the audience
certainly can't
we always have a a crowd at home
watching these these committee meetings
representative blackis thank you on one
related note is that please remember to
turn it off because I think there's a
maximum of three mics that can be live
at a time yes
all right
okay yes
thank you
okay so when you're ready
all right
go on the roll for Bill number 33 for
the motion Ito
representative Simon
yes
representative lakis yes
oh
representative Bailey
yes
representative Santana
sorry yes
representative true
yes
representative Dolan
representative a bear
yes
representative Gerhard
representative sarahway
yes
representative grody
representative Schmidt
oh
look at Cheryl look in the chair okay
representative goalie
yes
representative shewitt
representative O'Brien
yes
representative shurtleff
representative Davis
yes
representative Fitzpatrick
representative Gould
yes
representative rung
and representative
McGuire yes chair Madam chair
right
laughs
and we have 19 years
zero Nays all right the motion passes is
there any objection to consent
no representative O'Brien thank you
madam uh chair
um my only objection to consent is I
think that the bill swanser wants some
recognition with this
you don't have to explain you can okay
you object for any reason or no reason
at all I object okay we will put this on
the regular calendar then
no problem and uh
all right we are
coming out of executive session
having completed this yes representative
Schmidt
uh
I will do so once because it's mine
where several of us don't have any
function ah thank you I will take care
of it
yes thank you we'll we'll call uh I.T
about that and uh
we cannot start a public hearing early
our next one is scheduled for 10 45 so
everyone has a chance to get some coffee
and I'll call
I'd like to call Representative germanna
thanks
yeah
this is the public hearing on House Bill
65.
thank you madam chair
should I just
you have the floor all right thank you
uh thank you madam chair thank you uh
committee members didn't realize I would
be the only uh sponsor slash co-sponsor
uh talking to you this morning but I'm
happy to do that uh I am a first time
member of the of the house uh I am also
a professor of history at Keene State
College I'm not an American historian
I'm a German historian but uh this issue
and I when I was asked by representative
Gallagher about being a co-sponsor I
thought was a a great idea I am also a
sponsor of a bill
uh before another committee that would
uh have us for the state keep a
comprehensive list maintain a
comprehensive list of all the public
monuments in the state and and I was
just talking to representative Gerhard
about that because I think as a
historian it's really important that we
talk about our history and we
acknowledge our history and we take
great pride in it uh I want to have more
conversations about uh the great history
of our state so uh I think in this case
I was looking through some previous kind
of commemoration days or recognition
days that we have here in New Hampshire
all of them worthy no doubt uh
interesting Lafayette day right so not
even from New Hampshire but nonetheless
worthy
um uh also K-9 Veterans Day which I
think is a fabulous day to have the
Portsmouth peace treaty day which is
really great thinking about the the
history of New Hampshire within the
context of United States history and his
history of the world the importance of
the the peace treaty that was concluded
there
and I think that commemoration of the
strike at the Dover Mills in on December
the 30th of 1828 is also worthy of our
recognition uh we're all familiar I'm
sure with the importance of mills in in
the history of our State the importance
of New Hampshire in the united in New
England and in the United States is in
large part due to the importance of the
Mills uh that we had here and we are all
familiar I hope with a lot of the labor
practices that were dominant all
throughout New England in a lot of the
Mills and what we have on December 30th
1828 is an example of uh of a group of
strong New Hampshire women who uh were
facing an injustice they had already
which was the practice of the time of
course uh were paid considerably less
than the male workers within the Mills
but in addition to that they were being
required by new owners to take a uh a
pay cut on top of the already large
disparity between their pay and and the
pay of their male co-workers and they
decided that enough was enough and they
banded together and they made a powerful
statement uh about that Injustice and
and the power of Labor to resist in the
face of those types of of radical
inequalities so
um I would argue instead of having
looked at the commemoration dates that
we have already in the history of of our
great state that this is certainly
worthy of being included on that list
and I thank you for allowing me the time
thank you very much are there any
questions representative shurtleff
thank you madam chair thank you and
welcome to the New Hampshire house uh I
just wanted if you talked to the
division of historical resources about
the possibility of erecting a historic
marker in the middle area to commemorate
what you're proposing today
I will leave that question to the
sponsor representative Gallagher who has
just come in I know that Dover library
has uh um some commemoration I'm not
sure physically how it is commemorated
but I know in Dover there is some
emphasis on the event thank you okay
other questions representative O'Brien
uh thank you madam chair
um
kind of if you could put your professor
hat on are you sure the documentation
this was the first what about Lawrence's
uh bread and Roses uh they claim that
they were the person
thank you representative O'Brien
it is from from the research I have done
I think there's there's some question uh
about whether it was the first labor
action I believe that the more accurate
wording is the first labor action which
was led entirely by women which is not
insignificant historically so from uh
the the research that I have done I
believe that it is the first labor
strike LED entirely by women in the
United States
foreign
thank you I had the same concern because
when we discussed this last session
there was a question of whether it was
the first or not and Lawrence was
definitely brought up other questions
uh representative Bailey more like a
comment I guess we've got a research
document here that has a little footnote
to the United States that says
in all women's labor strike occurred in
1824 at a textile mill in Pawtucket
Rhode Island
and for that reason
the research doctor's saying this is the
first one in New Hampshire
I appreciate that clarification
okay thank you very much other questions
seeing none
very good representative
so
I um yeah please introduce yourself hi
I'm Eric Gallagher uh representative
from uh Concord Ward 6 which is
Merrimack County
District
um 20. so and I'm
here to present or testify to
House Bill 65 commemorating the first
labor strike in the United States by
women
um
and
yeah I'm just finding
um what I wrote about it
um
so yeah um
the history with
um so yeah my committee's Municipal and
County government which is having its
own hearing down the hall so
um yeah I'm just stepping out from that
briefly to come here for this um
so last term I had a bill
um House Bill 1144
which was to
require the teaching of Labor history in
schools so that went before
the education committee but they
generally don't like adding new
curriculum requirements
um so
I still wanted to do something to
increase the
awareness of Labor history
in this step because I think
knowing about past labor struggles can
help
students and workers prepare for the
labor struggles of
the present and future
so
I
managed to come across this other bill
that representative Frost
had sponsored last term
uh
so it was House Bill
170 last term
um so since she is
has left the legislature I
decided to pick it up
from her to
um
see if we could get past this term
and
um yeah I think it's just a generally
good way to
highlight an important event
from New Hampshire's labor history and
um to
show the
strong history we have here
of
worker workers standing up for
themselves
so that's for
what people mentioned about the one in
Lawrence
um
yeah if you look at the language
of the bill it says
the governor shall annually issue a
proclamation calling for a proper
observance of December 30th in
recognition of the first all-woman labor
strike in the state of New Hampshire so
it's got the words all women in there
that's what makes it different from the
one in Lawrence because
the one Lawrence was led by women but
they also had men joining in with them
so
this one however was all women which is
what makes it different
so yeah and you also have
um the
gender angle to to see it from besides
just the labor angle um
so
um
yeah that's why
that's why I think that
it's sufficiently
um different from the one in Lawrence to
still be considered the first
um
so although I I am willing to
um entertain an amendment to add the
word entirely to the title if that helps
clarify clarify things further
um first labor strike entirely by women
um but
um
yeah I I think that
that would just be reinforcing
the distinction that's already made in
the document by saying a woman
um
so
that's
about what I have to say about the bill
and I'll take any questions now
thank you representative Gallagher are
there any questions from the committee
representative true
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question do you know if dova
has any ceremonies and activities around
that date around in December
um no I don't
um
yeah I
I'm actually not too well connected
um with Dover myself I'm more just
taking this up as something that
happened in New Hampshire and
um
is a good thing to commemorate I think
having recognizing it at the state level
would be good even if it is also
recognized at the local level
other questions
okay seeing none thank you very much
representative Gallagher and I call
Representative Reed
thank you madam chair and thank you
honorable members of the committee for
the record my name is Ellen Reed I
represent Newmarket and new Fields I am
more familiar with Dover Dover is one
town over from me it's where I go and do
a lot of my shopping so this is
something that is
um I actually sought out Eric to add my
name because I very much wanted to be on
this bill and I'm honored to be on it I
want to First say and oh and by the way
two of my very good friends
independently live in the Dover Mills
where this happened so it is very I've
walked through the Mills repeatedly many
many times
um the first thing I want to say about
this is while this obviously talks about
women and it talks about Labor I want
you to divorce your Notions of 2023
women's issues 2023 labor issues we're
not talking about 2023 and we're not
talking about 1923 we're talking about
1828.
100 years before women got the right to
vote
so when we talk about Labor and women
issues is very very different from what
we are currently thinking about
um
and just to put that in perspective 50
years ago a single woman 50 years ago
not 250 50 years ago a woman a single
woman couldn't get a credit card or a
bank account in the lifetimes of people
who are still very much with us and
active today in 1972 or it wasn't until
1972 women were even allowed to run the
Boston Marathon because women's hips
couldn't take it so if that's what we're
talking about how we think of Women
Within peoples very much within people's
lifetimes today it's hard it's a hard
stretch but I'm asking you to stretch
with me to think about 1828 because in
1828 women in very many ways were
essentially for more more or less slaves
and in fact that's actually one of the
reasons the women at this particular
mill strike struck or striked is because
um they were being quote this is their
quote abused and insulted and called
slaves and this was quite intentional
because women could be paid quite a bit
less
and very very very specifically the ads
that were put out at the time requested
girls to apply so it wasn't like today's
standards where people just apply and
maybe there's some kind of Social and
spoken discrimination no they were
saying we want girls specifically
between 12 and 25 because those are the
the more vulnerable people who could be
um it coerced into accepting those
conditions and in taking that very low
pay so it was a very much an intentional
way of exploiting young women
um also not only did they experience a
pay cut and that was one of the
precipitating events but also they were
being their pay speed was being
increased they were expected to produce
more for less money and with those other
abuses that is why they finally striked
but again
these women it this is really almost
before women's issues were at the
Forefront and like something that was
like a household term these women
honestly considered themselves very much
in the spiritual vein of the American
Revolution which was not that long
before this was in the lifetimes of
their mothers right the American
Revolution only 50 years prior so
um when they striked they marched around
with martial Music Military music they
waved banners and they set off artillery
so they they literally set off barrels
of gunpowder so they very much were what
they felt they were doing was in the
spirit of the American Revolution
fighting for the rights of regular
everyday people the the downtrodden so
the fact that this happened the fact
that the least Among Us the fact that
the least powerful people girls even by
today's standard is a 12 year old girl
really has no social power but that they
all by themselves without any help of
men uh led the first strike is
significant in Something New Hampshire
should be shouting from the rooftops
that this is our proud history this is
the kind of stock that New Hampshire has
and that is why I think it's very very
important that you all commemorate uh
this with a day
um and I will say that being in Dover I
don't know of any dover-specific uh and
I and I would think I would
um over specific events however
um as was mentioned the library does
have resources on this and the New
England historical society as well so uh
with that I'll I'll take questions
thank you very much are there any
questions
ah representative rung thank you madam
chair representative Reed is it possible
that the governor could issue this
Proclamation without having it go into
statute
uh sure but
um I don't like trusting any other
branch of government to do what we can
do so
I'm happy to do it on our own
thank you other questions
all right thank you very much
does anyone else wish to testify on
House Bill 65
all right seeing none I will close the
public hearing
and
we'll go into executive session without
objection
representative Aber you have a motion
yes thank you madam chair I would like
to make a motion to expedience to
legislate thank you is there a second
okay second by representative true do
you wish to speak to your motion sorry
thank you madam chair I will speak to my
motion
I think that the comments regarding
strong New Hampshire women today in 2023
is
is a fantastic journey of the last 194
years and I think the people who
sponsored and co-sponsored this
I've worked for
30 years in a man-driven industry and I
believe truly that the more that we
speak out about being different we are
treated more differently so I think that
that is uh that is my perspective and
also I think a Governor's Proclamation
would be fine and would not cost the
taxpayers monies in uh building any
statues or anything like that thank you
do you wish to speak to your second
okay does anyone else wish to comment
representative O'Brien
thank you madam chair those on the
committee that know me into the build
sponsors I have a very long career in
labor and I generally do support labor
but the other hat that I wear is on the
City Board of Alderman and I would be
encouraged if this town of Dover which
has the authority
in Dover itself to come out and support
this particular bill before we do it
Statewide so basically I'll leave it at
that as my comment thank you
anyone anyone else
representative Gerhard thank you madam
chair
I would like to thank the speakers for
coming and history is very important and
I think we should talk about it much
much more than we do
at the same time
I I just all right driving into work the
other day they were talking about the
different days and National Twinkie day
and you know we've come up to this point
where there's just
every day for everything and I just
worry that it's it's watering down the
truly significant events where if we
actually have physical events occurring
in person where people can talk and ex
so that's my position thank you very
much all right anyone else
representative
uh thank you I you know want to Second
what representative O'Brien said
um not just because it was in Dover and
it should be limited to Dover not the
state but having a group of people
organize an event and you might get some
news coverage is going to be a lot more
effective than having the governor's
staff present them with a piece of paper
to sign and maybe this press release and
that's the end of it which I think is
what happens with these things thank you
all right anyone else
all right seeing none
oh there she is city of Representative
shuitt sorry it's hard to see Crossing
in this table yet
um I would just say that uh also as a
strong supporter of Labor and um I think
I'm pretty well recognized for that fact
that I would remind the sponsors that we
have seen this bill before on a couple
of iterations
and I don't know if if this last two
sponsors were here when the first
comment was made that this whole issue
for the first in the United States has
been disputed
uh by a strike that occurred in Rhode
Island
which we've heard was all women and
that's why this iteration was denied by
this committee last term
we had
doubts as to whether the research was
really complete in both issues and
therefore we turned it down
and I was kind of sad to see that this
came out again saying for strike in the
United States
um I think it is a proud moment for New
Hampshire we do have a member on this
committee from Dover who has stated that
he would like to see Dover make a big
deal out of this and I think that's the
way to approach it thank you
you could also I would also like to
comment that since December 30th you
might as well tie it in with the New
Year's Eve celebrations which in many
cities like Portsmouth and and
Manchester take place in the millyards
it'd be entirely appropriate so anyway
that's a sideline any other comments
all right seeing none the motion is
inexpeding to legislate by
representative a bear or seconded by
representative true and the clerk can
call the roll
foreign
build number 65.
representative Simon yes
representative leckis yes representative
Bailey yes
representative Santo NATO
yes representative true yes
representative Dolan
oh I'm sorry
representative a bear
yes
representative Gerhard
representative sirway yes
representative groda
regrettably yes
representative Schmidt
yes
representative goalie
representative shewitt
yes
representative O'Brien
representative shurtleff
yes
representative Davis
representative Fitzpatrick
yes
representative Gould
representative rung
yes
and representative Madam chair Maguire
and within about 19 yay to zero nay
okay not seeing any we'll put this one
on consent
come out of executive session and we
have
15 minutes before our next hearing so
I'm
um
that's right
yes sir
all right it being 11 30.
I'm opening the hearing on
house bill 94.
are any of the sponsors here
after you speak please put in a pink
card and
Lundgren okay
Pro tip
say representative linger
thank you
for your time
representing Londonderry District 16.
it's a bill I've uh
excuse me representative can you turn
your mic on please
your microphone thank you so much is it
on now okay thank you
all right anyway eczema is a atopic
dermatitis it's common uh type is eczema
it's results from an overactive immune
system that causes uh
this condition can uh occur at any part
of the body and has varied symptoms
um
the thing that I really wanted to hit on
was that it affects uh 9.6 million
children in the United States and about
16.5 million uh adults in the United
States
um it's an inflammatory condition and
uh
other than getting into the medical
start of it uh
that's essentially what I uh it was
asked by a constituent to to submit this
and and she's here to give further
testimony but if you have any questions
for me I'd be happy to try to
answer it thank you representative are
there any questions from the committee
uh representative
um thank you maybe you can answer this
or maybe the person asked for it can and
that is
um I understand you want to raise
awareness but what action do you want to
have happen as part of that I mean is it
you know awareness among
people that might have it not know what
they have among the medical community or
what I I think she could probably answer
that better than me if that's okay
other questions
not seeing them thank you very much
thanks so much for your time
Lisa boyan
good morning good morning uh
my name is Lisa boyan I'm from
Londonderry this is my son Matthew my
daughter Paige and my husband Lou
we come here today to speak in favor of
House Bill 94 to help raise awareness
about Eczema
Matthew has suffered with eczema his
whole life
eczema is a skin condition that causes
dry itchy inflamed skin
most people think of eczema as a small
dry patch of skin
but for most patients including Matthew
it impacts their entire body
it impacts the quality of life by
causing lack of sleep mental health
issues
and out-of-pocket Healthcare class
the impacts of living with eczema go
beyond health concerns
children with eczema are reported to
have an increased number of missed
school days
and they have experienced bullying due
to their skin condition
parents of children with eczema average
fewer than five hours of sleep per night
impacting their work day
one school year Matthew had 81 visits to
the nurse which resulted in Miss
classroom time
he's been hospitalized three times
so we ask you to help us raise awareness
about the burden of this disease
to help increase funding on the state
and federal level level for research
and to increase or to improve the
quality of life for these patients
I appreciate your time and Matthew would
like to say a few words about how eczema
has impacted his life
okay thank you
hello I'm Matt boyon and I'm 17 years
old I've suffered from severe severe
eczema my whole life
um to start I would like to thank you
for your time and listening to my story
um eczema doesn't only affect me
physically but it affects me mentally as
well
ever since elementary school I've gone
through bullying at school due to rashy
skin and at home scratching cause welts
and rashes which affects me which
affects my my mental health because it
it causes a negative image of myself
um through Sports I play hockey and
soccer
um The Sweat causes it causes more
rashes on my skin and that that causes
oh sorry
um this the sweat from Sports because I
cause irritation in my skin uh
I'm sorry I'm sorry
it causes burning and irritation
um at home at home I require 24 7 care
which is a lot on my parents and
immediate family
and it just plays a whole negative part
in my life
um through school since elementary
middle and high school I've had to miss
school through nurse visits or
just having to stay at home because of
my skin
um to finish out I would just like to
fit uh to thank representative Lundgren
for filing the bill and I would like to
thank the committee for listening to my
story
thank you for your testimony
is there anyone who has any questions
representing Broda
I want to thank you for coming and being
so brave
to come to speak to us today it's
remarkable
and I also want to thank your family
for for the support that they've given
you
and that if the fact that you've all
come together is incredibly touching and
memorable thank you
thank you
any other questions comments
represent Gould
thank you you're very brave and you're
very handsome and don't listen to the
bullies thank you very much
anyone else representative rung thank
you madam chair Matthew I just want to
repeat what my colleagues have said
um thank you so much for coming in for
sharing your story and for your family
I've learned more about Eczema through
your testimony than I knew before so
um you've reached one person for sure
I'm sure all of us so thank you thank
you very much representative Broda
I do want to ask the question that
representative Lucas so eloquently asked
because
this bill
just says we're aware you know raise
awareness
and so it would appear like that in
Statue and that's where it would stay
so what is it exactly that you're
looking for
when you say raise awareness because we
might be able to direct help in that way
so we're hoping by raising awareness but
this will increase funding for the for
research of this disease and various
treatments
representative Gerhard
thank you madam chair I'm not really
sure about this are there treatments
available that are effective I remember
I had when I was younger I remember
there was like a packet you put in the
bathtub and you soak in it and then that
was that but obviously I passed through
that phase I guess so I'm just curious
about what type of treatments yes is it
there's something readily available or
is this some kind of a super expensive
there's a lot of new medications in the
market
um when Matt was an infant he would have
to take bleach baths he'd have to take
tar bass topical steroids
um a treatment called wet wraps now
there's a lot more medications on the
market
for adults
thank you thank you anyone else
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair uh it it seems to
me that there's a currently uh an ad
campaign going on television uh for a
particular product I I I I don't have
any experience in my family so uh it's
not something that I'm fixated on or
that we ought to try that uh so I can't
tell you what the name of the product is
in other words it must be a bad ad uh
but it you're all nodding and
recognition maybe depiction
I I didn't get the name because but I've
seen the ad over and over and over again
so and this is the disease you're
talking about right
it shows it shows the people with the
red patches on the elbows yes yes and so
forth yes that is eczema correct
thank you
anyone else
yes
that's okay thank you
thank you uh representative Fitzpatrick
good question uh the question it is the
biggest is the ad that we're seeing on
TV
um you're seeing more and more companies
now on the outside invest in this Tech
in uh remedies for eczema only because
it's becoming more prevalent in our
society as Mr Lundgren spoke about 25
million people in this world in this
country are affected by eczema to a
certain degree so it's not just Matthew
and Matthew's come a long way so he's 17
now he's come a long way in this we're
not looking for sympathy for Matthew but
we're we're representing other people
who have been afflicted by by eczema so
um I I hope we addressed your questions
with bringing bringing awareness to the
to to eczema for other people
um and yes uh you were seeing more and
more ads coming online for uh for
depiction and other related uh Therapies
could I just follow up man follow up so
uh this product is being advertised uh
it do you have any personal experience
with it whether whether that's something
that you see the ads and you don't know
whether it really works or not like Flex
Seal for your drains and so forth you're
going like does it really work or not so
the pixin is actually an injectable
um there's there are topicals and
they're injectables and they each have a
different degree of efficacy some work
better than others I would say that the
depiction the one that you're seeing on
TV is probably more uh more invasive on
the body whereas a topical you can
control the amount of steroid that you
apply to your skin and they have
different degrees from a scale of one to
seven as it's explained so if you have a
more severe case of atopic dermatitis
you may put on a emollient or a or a
topical
um that's stronger if you have less
eczema to your skin maybe you go with
something less less invasive on the skin
on the body
thank you very much thank you
any other questions
representative goalie
thank you madam chair and I want to
thank you folks for coming here
um it's
not often at all we have a whole family
testified before us so it's great to see
um
I was just looking briefly online
because I always like when these bills
come before us to see if there's
National recognition for a lot of these
issues and are you aware that October is
eczema awareness month I'm looking at
the
um
website of the national eczema
Association
so we do a lot of work with the national
eczema Association so they've declared
October awareness month for their
organization but we're trying to
bring awareness at the state level as
well
thank you
anyone else representative
um I like I second the uh you know
thanking you for coming and uh
my concern is that
you know if this passes what will happen
is the governor will be presented
something to sign there may be a press
release and that's probably about it
my concern is it won't really do
anything effectively to raise awareness
probably Those ads raised tremendously
more awareness
than something like this and I'm just
wondering if there's something
else that could be done that might
actually be effective but my concern is
this wouldn't be
I've joined a legislative panel with the
national eczema Association
um and we're working on efforts to to
raise awareness so
um there'll be things coming down the
pike if this is past
um to increase awareness
follow-up
so
could those things occur with or without
this bill
I mean how you know they haven't they
have not done so already
thank you
any else anyone else represent Broda
so one of the things that you wanted to
result one of the things that you've
said
is that you want funding for research
and this I don't know how this bill does
that
well to raise awareness about the burden
of this disease so that people don't
think that eczema is just a dry patch of
skin that there is a lot more to it
there's an emotional component there's
um
a lifestyle impact
and there's a burden of this of this
disease
thank you you're welcome okay
anyone else
all right well I'd like to reiterate our
thanks for you for you to come and
inform us on this
does anyone else wish to testify on
House Bill 94.
okay there is nobody else
so I'll close the public hearing
thank you okay
okay
without objection I'd like to go into
executive session
representative goalie
thank you madam chair I
move in expedient to legislate on House
Bill 94. is there a second
representative O'Brien thank you do we
should speak to your motion
yes I do and I first want to thank the
family for coming here
um
we see numerous
bills before this committee the first
two we heard today were naming days and
months and we take that um not a
light-hearted um there are quite a few
naming days weeks and months in statute
that I think uh a lot of people out
there are not aware of it's nice to put
it into statute or Proclaim it but I I
think the more effective way because
this is just proclaiming October
2023 as eczema awareness month is and I
would strongly suggest to this family to
reach out to the governor's office with
their
plea to
recognize this if it's going to be for
one month the governor does this quite
often when approached versus having to
come to the legislature in the
legislature having to go through this
process it's done on an often thing so I
I would strongly recommend taking that
route and seeing the government have it
done I think you'll get more press doing
it that way with you folks around him
and
representative
thank you madam chair I would like to
Second the thoughts of
uh the representative from Manchester
representative Cooley and I do wish the
family well and thank you for appearing
uh Matt you played hockey I played
hockey
and I know what it is to smell like cold
talk
but the thing is this itl vote please do
not be discouraged continue on and go
forward you know don't even consider the
time in The Penalty Box although I did
enjoy my time there
but the thing is you're a handsome young
man you got your whole life in front of
you uh and I think it is saying what
representative goalie has stated it may
be a bad attack for the family to follow
so uh consider me supporting that in the
future with you and uh and looking
forward because it is something that
affects an awful lot of America thank
you
okay does anyone else comment
representative garota
I just want you to know that all of our
contact information is on the website
so be sure to check us up on your our
offer to help you and contact us that's
we're here for
anyone else
all right seeing no further comments the
motion is inexpecting to legislate by
representative goalie seconded by
representative O'Brien on House Bill 94.
the clerk can call the rule
now taking the boat roll for building
the number 94.
representative chairman uh sorry Vice
chairman Simon yes
representative lakis yes
representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nasato yes
representative true yes
representative a bear
yes
representative Gerard yes
representative stairway yes
representative groda
yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie
yes
representative schuette
I'm voting no in the in hopes that
someone else may go with me and
so that at least there will be a
discussion on the floor thank you
representative O'Brien
yes
representative shurliff
representative Davis
yes
representative Fitzpatrick
representative Gould
I'm following Diane's lead in voting no
so it goes to the floor
representative rung yes
and
common failing sorry and Madam chair yes
regular calendar you just have to object
to consent as representative Brian did
on a different Road
so I take it this is on the regular
calendar
yes I object to consent okay very good
it'll be on the regular calendar
okay
coming out of executive session we will
resume at 1 pm on our next hearing and
thank you all
so practice it differently what makes
the most in your expectations
yep that's why we keep track
come on again
I think I need some air
all right good afternoon welcome back to
Edna
I'm opening up the public hearing and
house resolution 12 and I call
Representative hacken Phillips to
introduce it
good afternoon
uh just as a matter of introduction I'm
representative Mary heck and Phillips
and I represent Grafton County District
12.
which are the great towns of Hanover and
lime
so thank you to the committee for
hearing this legislation today and
allowing me to introduce it
um
so as you'll see it's house resolution
designating November 2023 as National
Lung Care awareness month and expressing
support for the early detection and
treatment of lung cancer
as you may know or may not know that
lung cancer is a deadly disease
and it has the highest mortality rate
for cancer among other cancer rates in
the US and in worldwide measurements
but the good news is that this terrible
disease is treatable
and especially if it's caught in the
early stages
um and increasingly becomes survivable
if you're like me you didn't know that
you know it's very possible to to get
diagnosed with lung cancer without
having ever smoked
and I understand that
um common worldwide rates is one in
every four cancer lung cancer diagnosis
is for a person who's never
smoke themselves
um
so while this may be the most deadly
form of cancer
diagnosis and mortality rate
in the United States it is one of those
lowest amounts of screening rates so
lung cancer currently
has about a six percent screen rate
but other forms of cancer screenings
such as breast cancer colon cancer they
have higher rates of 60 to 80 percent of
screening rates so even though it's more
deadly it's much much significantly less
screened for
so it's a critical issue but you don't
have to take my my word for it
um so in your online testimony for the
committee's official record you'll see
there's strong support from the
comprehensive lung cancer physicians in
our state which I believe there are five
existing Thoracic Surgeons in the state
and four of them have submitted
testimony on this issue
and those Thoracic Surgeons reside at
Dartmouth Healthcare and the Health Care
system up in Lebanon New Hampshire
there's also strong support for this
resolution coming from Thoracic Surgeons
across the country the American lung
cancer screening initiative
Representatives have also also submitted
testimony supporting this resolution
furthermore you'll see that there is
strong support from the healthcare
nonprofit sector here in our state in
fact one of the non-profits known as
Thorn or thoracic
surgery outcomes research Network Inc
was unable to submit testimony online in
time for today's
um hearing but doesn't in fact know of
the resolution and support it as well
um the reasoning that this screening is
so important is that
um you know you can just look to the
most recent medical literature in fact
in the January 2023 Journal of thoracic
surgery there's a new study out entitled
stage shift improves lung cancer
survival the real real world evidence
this primary author whose name is Dr
yang
provides the main finding that although
lung cancer incidence keeps increasing
throughout the world that the mortality
rate is actually decreasing gradually
for all stages of cancer and especially
when early detection
is able to identify more localized lung
cancer as opposed to a larger advanced
disease
so
what can we do as a Statewide Community
to you know recognize the issue of lung
cancers to increase this awareness is my
answer and to say
you know it's our responsibility as
leaders in the state to promote the
advanced screening and greater
eligibility for folks
um to get the test to find out whether
or not you know they have early stage
cancer
um the good news is that eligibility for
screening for lung cancer has recently
expanded and more Granite Staters can be
screened and avoid you know becoming
other Cancer Victim
instead you know by receiving this early
detection they can be part of the new
numbers of survivors even you know the
highest lung cancer
is found
procedurally I just like the committee
to know that the legislation was
submitted in the form of a resolution
based on the previous
um
attempts by similar entities proposing
legislation across the United States so
my understanding is that there are a
handful dozens in fact other states who
have passed similar resolutions already
but of course we are open I am open as
the primary sponsor to amending this
legislation to make it a proper House
Bill if that's what the committee
determines is more effective
finally I'd just like to say that this
is a personal matter for me
I'm in fact a married medicine to one of
the Thoracic Surgeons who did sign some
of the testimony that was submitted to
you
in fact
um it's even more personal lung cancer
has claimed multiple members of my
family
as well as my neighbors so
whatever amount of good that this
legislation could potentially do for the
state and granite Staters
broadly is you know a wonderful gift to
our state and I think if if this
recognition can even save one life it
will be a day of good work here in the
New Hampshire house
so with that I urge the committee to
support unanimously the passage of this
house resolution and I'm happy to take
any questions
thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee
representative
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um most resolutions that urge
recognition of this type of want
somebody to notify somebody
normally it's to have the governor make
a proclamation or to notify members of
our Congressional Delegation things of
that sort I don't see anything like that
in this resolution
has the governor already done this kind
of thing does he do this on an annual
basis do you know
thank you representative for the
question
um as I previously mentioned in my
introduction
um the format of this legislation is
pretty much a carbon copy of the
previous submissions across the United
States to other states who have adopted
the resolution so
um it does not include a notification
type mechanism as you've indicated might
be helpful and I'm definitely open to
you know providing an amendment that
might do the kind of thing that you're
asking for I think
um
or what you're looking for I should say
um I think you know I'm here to take the
advice of the committee to find out you
know the best possible way to move
forward to affect the most you know
possible changes possible so thank you
follow up thank you um
has your group that you represent
notified the governor of this or
attempted to have the governor do
recognition previously
my understanding is that the American
Lung Cancer
excuse me the American lung cancer
screening initiative has previously had
contact with the governor of our state
but
he or the main representative of that
group has directly contacted me to also
see if there's some momentum because
um it doesn't sound like they got as far
as they had hoped through the executive
office
thank you representative Gerhart thank
you madam chair
you mentioned the screening has been
improved the access to it is is lung
cancer screening prohibitively expensive
what is the what is the problem getting
people screened exactly just curious I
know sure
um probably that question is best
directed to the Physicians who have
submitted the online testimony and I
hope that they address it in their
letters to you I'm thinking back and I'm
not sure it does but from my
understanding
um is that recently the eligibility
criteria nationally has expanded so that
more Americans are eligible for this
reimbursable screening process through
their insurance
um so the idea is that um even in the
last I think
as recent as the last few years the
amount the rates of of the amount of
Americans who are actually taking
advantage of that screening program has
more than doubled so
um I think the reality is that many
people who are eligible don't realize
that this is something that they are
you know that they can Embrace and take
advantage of the program so that's kind
of what we're here today to decide is
what can we do as state legislators to
increase that awareness and I'm hopeful
that this piece of legislation will help
trigger that knowledge if you look into
the
actual context of the resolution itself
it talks about you know the deadliness
and
um the ability to screen
and you know trying to drive those
numbers up and in statistically speaking
I think the more people who get screened
the more lives can be saved so even that
small two percent increase over a
five-year
you know for cancer screens is Gonna
Save countless lives so
um I'm sorry I can't speak particularly
you know
and great detail to your question but I
think generally that's the idea that
eligibility for reimbursement used to be
much more controlled and it's become
expanded recently
representative thank you this is maybe a
question for you or somebody
um there have been some references to
written testimony and maybe email sent
I'm looking at my rep email I'm not
seeing anything it was not sent by email
it was submitted via the the house
testimony process which
I'm afraid we don't get very often in
this committee but we'll have to figure
out where it is and how to get it to
people I also can forward
um both of the copies that I have
received via PDF to the company if
that's something that's helpful thank
you I think that will be helpful to
getting it to us sooner
representative Schmidt
thank you man I'm sure
so representative you referenced uh some
possibility of amendment uh and have you
been thinking about what the content of
that Amendment might be because
the committee is
heard a number of bills this morning and
ongoing members incumbent members have
heard a number of this type of bills
over the years that we've served
and and frankly we find that it's it
doesn't really accomplish very much kind
of words on written on the Wind
what do you have in mind with regard to
uh possibility of having some greater
toothiness if you will uh and with
regard to your resolved clause
well representative thank you for the
question
um in particularly I'm thankful because
um
you know this is my first crack at the
Apple of trying to find a resolution to
pass this body
um to help raise awareness across the
state for a specific month of the of a
specific year for a specific issue
I am hopeful that because the cancer
rate for this disease is amongst the
highest
um and is has the highest mortality rate
in the country for any other cancerous
disease that this committee will take
special recognition of that you know
status and consider this to be one of
the worthy projects before put before
this body and to answer your questions
specifically
I am open and um
will commit to you to work very hard to
try to find a way to not only make this
resolution on paper something that we
can promote as a body but also to find
some action in the private sector to
support this resolution there are
clearly enough Physicians and you know
nationally based as long as state as
well as state-based Physicians who
directly deal with this disease that are
already behind this effort
um so you know they're going to continue
to do the things that they do in their
private sector jobs to promote that
awareness but we will be the missing key
of the public sector to support them in
their Endeavors and this is one way to
to get that motion moving in the same
direction so
um I like I'm trying to express to you
perhaps not very well that I'm willing
to take whatever recommendation the
committee has
to try to make that eventuality come to
fruition
thank you
um
so as you are certainly aware uh vaping
was a topic du jour for quite a while
more than just a couple of days and
there was some drop off there was some
action taken I Believe by the federal
government with regard to vaping and yet
you still see you know I still see
people driving by with big clouds of
smoke coming out of their vehicle maybe
not during these days but anyway
so people are still getting into vaping
children are still taking up vaping if
they can get a hold of stuff so we we
we're not a medical committee
we don't have any expertise in that area
so I think that
the ideas are going to have to come from
your side rather than from us
thank you representative for that
important
um
you know reflection of you know the
responsibility we bear
you know just in considering this
legislation and myself as the prime
sponsor I I'm keenly aware
um of the private sector's work
um and to mention vaping is a part a
small part of the you know larger scheme
of lung cancer disease uh you know
awareness that we're trying to
to promulgate through this legislation
so
um you know I think there is larger
genetic concerns larger familial
concerns as well as you know smoking
vaping that also contribute to this
disease so
um
you know I understand it's an uphill
battle
um to try to get folks to understand
that they're eligible to be aware of the
disease screening and that you know if
you are diagnosed with the disease that
you can treat it if you act quickly and
you know consult with medical
professionals
you know I think every step in the right
direction of trying to increase that
awareness and to you know help people
make the decision to be screened and to
be treated is going to be a huge huge
Plus for you know our mortality rates as
a society
so I I wasn't trying to point you in the
direction of vaping but just giving it
an example of something that was a big
subject of conversation and controversy
a couple of years ago uh and uh there
was some action was taken but your your
whereas Clauses
reflect the fact that there are many
people who get into lung cancer they
never smoked their family never smoked
maybe so uh but again we're not a
medical committee so the impulses I
think are going to have to come from you
thank you
any other representing Broda
representative Phillips um
the issue that I have
is that
you say in your
resolution that
the people of New Hampshire and
encourages the people of New Hampshire
to observe National Lung awareness month
with appropriate awareness and
educational activities
and I don't know how that's gonna happen
because of this bill
or this resolution
and I guess that the the issue that we
have as a committee with these type of
things is that
although the intent is sincere and
passionate
there isn't a vehicle to in New
Hampshire
to
carry out this mission
it has to be done through
either a Board of Medicine or and
non-profit organization we simply don't
have the infrastructure to do that and
so
we tend not to
support this type because we think that
it's misleading just put this in a piece
of paper that's going to end up in a
book on the Shelf I never looked at
again does that make sense it does
representative thank you for that
comment and I guess my response to that
is that rest assured that the private
sector here in the state of New
Hampshire and across New England and
across the country impact the world are
already putting those private actions
into motion
so by asking you know by designing this
legislation as a resolution my
understanding is that a resolution
reflects the opinion of the body a
unanimous opinion of the body
so um I hope that
um that opinion is that we would like to
promote the screening and the awareness
of lung cancer screening and that this
disease is preventable is treatable
if caught
um
so if it's the opinion of the body
through a house resolution that they
support this private sector work that's
being done here in the state for
instance by the Dartmouth Healthcare
Thoracic Surgeons or you know the
American lung cancer screening
initiative that's ongoing through the
Norris cotton
um or through the Norris cotton Cancer
Center that's also located at Dartmouth
that are you know these events are
happening these motions are already
taking place with the resolution
reflects is that it's the body's opinion
that we support them and it's by by
doing so I hope to increase that
awareness across the state so I think
you know rightfully so the committee
should be guarded for
um you know request that
say there will be events and motions in
place to support but then there's no
mechanism to enact that
um I think in this case those efforts
are already being undertaken and in fact
what we're asking for is the state to
put its stamp on approval
um on this on this General
National
effort like other states have done so
um
I think hopefully that answers your
question it does thank you
or any any other questions comments yes
representative Gould
so if I'm hearing correctly in order to
achieve your objectives is it necessary
that November be designated as lung
cancer month or could there be
um a house resolution supporting the
efforts of the private sector in raising
awareness of lung cancer and screening
opportunities
thank you representative for the
question
um my understanding through speaking
with these Physicians who are nationally
based and practice the standards of care
for lung cancer disease is that
it's already a nationally recognized
month November every year and so that's
why
um we're tagging it for this upcoming
November in this legislation so if it's
a reoccurring National
um
awareness campaign that New Hampshire
will with approval of this legislation
will join that effort by designating and
declaring
follow-up follow-up
so if it's already a national holiday
and our physicians and treatment
Specialists are already following those
protocols would a resolution of the
house to support the efforts of the
private sector not support that National
month without having to name it and
and get into this messy business of so
many holidays
that we're naming
thank you for the question
um I don't believe I'm asking for them
last paragraph sorry yeah I'm trying to
rephrase my response so
um
I don't believe that there's any reason
why we can't have a more generalized you
know house resolution that just
uh kind of dampens down the
particularity of when we would like to
support lung cancer awareness
um and I'm sure that the Physicians who
support this legislation would also
support the general idea of lung cancer
awareness at any time of the year I just
we're trying our best to match up with
what other states have done so that the
effort can be seen as a larger push
across the country so
um of course we are open and amenable to
any recommended changes that you feel
are important
other questions
okay thank you very much representative
thank you
okay
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
see anybody
in that case I'll close the public
hearing on house resolution 12.
and
without objection we can go into
executive session and representative
sanostaso do you have a motion
uh thank you ma'am chair I move uh
motion itl recommended itl for this bill
uh
is there a second
by representative true do you wish to
speak to your motion
representative sentence uh yeah this is
already a nationally recognized day and
I believe uh lung cancer is pretty well
known as a terrible disease uh the
national Consciousness already
um and that any that this kind of thing
isn't going to do anything to raise
additional awareness
uh it's just going to be more uh more
statue that we're going to have to
maintain
representative true
thank you madam chair uh going along
with those thoughts a screening for Lung
Care lung cancer that was testified is
very low
and uh lung cancer is a very deadly
disease
well I do not believe that by passing a
simple resolution we will be raising the
awareness
of these issues for anyone that it's uh
it's really up to hospitals medical
organizations to uh to use their clout
to to increase awareness of this
terrible disease
thank you madam chair does anyone else
have a comment of Representative Bailey
more like a question I guess I I know
philosophically would generally kind of
opposed to these days
but where this is a house resolution
instead of a house bill does that change
things at all
it means that it won't have to go to the
senate or the governor
uh that's one thing does it change our
view
well it's certainly better than putting
it in statute because this is a one-time
designation and it will not go into the
statutes uh to be permanent it just be
listed as session law for one one time
so yes it's slightly less of a problem
than some of the others
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair uh so I I have a
thought that uh representative Hawkins
Phillips has uh indicated uh a
willingness to come back to us with
something that has
more truthiness as I was calling it more
bite on the issue and uh I don't know
that we're in any uh race to uh to get
the rid of this uh or to and to act on
it in absence of uh of seeing what she
might come up with so I'm disposed to
giving her a little bit of time to come
back to us with something because I
don't like the idea of putting things in
statute but as you pointed out this
gives us a little bit more
um
leeway thank you
representative blackis thank you um
there's I mean it seems like the issue
is getting more people screened
um and I think there may be a better way
to do it it was something suggested for
some of the earlier bills which is go to
the Board of Medicine I'll note that um
you know there's an online for me for
where I get insurance as an online thing
reminding me to get various screenings
and I've noticed there's not never been
anything in there about lung cancer so
the question is
if it's that common and the screening is
that valuable and it's not that
difficult or expensive to do why isn't
that one of the screenings which is
regularly recommended and I think that
would be a question for the Board of
Medicine not really anything we can do
here and that'd be my suggestion rather
than doing this
thank you madam chair
um
with regards to it being a house
resolution as opposed to a house bill it
doesn't have to go to the Senate it also
doesn't have to go to the governor
correct because it's just us I I'm sure
it doesn't go to the Senate I I don't
believe it goes to the governor right
which would give it even less of a
microphone than a bill would give it if
it were to pass and my concern because
obviously I think we're probably
unanimous and are concerned that's been
brought before us as far as the content
is concerned we're concerned about lung
cancer awareness and things of that
nature and I believe the representative
did an admirable job representing that
today but if the goal is to provide a
microphone in order to help to
promulgate that message a house
resolution to my mind gives it even less
of a platform less of a microphone than
a house bill would give it
I would tend to agree that the house
resolution doesn't
get a whole lot of attention outside of
the house and and unfortunately there
are very few active physicians in the
house most of them are retired so we we
may be aware but I don't know who else
would be affected by it
anyone else
representative Schmidt
thank you again one thing that occurs to
me that is referenced in the whereas
Clauses at one point in any case that we
should all be aware of and that is the
New Hampshire is an as extremely high
incidence of radon
prevalence uh the granite state is a it
is a nice terminology but it has its
downsides as well so uh radon screening
is something that we could all benefit
from having greater consciousness of so
that something I wanted to bring to the
committee's attention
I would agree and
as representative leckis mentioned the
the insurance the
your insurance tends to say
you know get your colonoscopy get your
flu shot get your uh get your mammogram
get this get you know this screening us
process and why why aren't they
encouraging us to get
um
lung cancer screening
which will probably be paid as much
attention to as we do all the others but
but at least they should be asking for
it and the primary care physicians are
the ones who need to to be aware that
they should ask for it
particularly as you say in the state in
the granite state where radon is
unfortunately prevalent
all right my two cents anyone else
all right
uh seeing none the motion is inexpedient
to legislate by representative sandton
assasso seconded by representative true
and the clerk can call the role
now take a vote rule for house
resolution 12.
representative Simon yes
representative lakis yes
representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes
representative a bear
yes
representative Gerhard yes
representative sarway yes
representative groda yes
representative Schmidt
no
representative goalie yes
representative shewitt
yes
representative O'Brien
representative shirtleff
yes
representative Davis
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould
yes
representative rung yes
we got 18 yeah oh I'm sorry madam chair
McGuire
so with the vote to 1801
18 D.A one day
the motion passes is is there an
objection to consent
no okay
no one objects we'll put it on consent
and
leave the executive session and we have
a few minutes before the next bill 145.
so
your question
do you get your email address
okay
welcome back to Edna
we are now have the hearing on House
Bill 140 and I call Representative
Horrigan
I also have some written testimony which
I'm
passing around in which I uh also uh
also submitted through the website to
the remote sign-in feature but I have no
idea what happens if anything happens to
those files that are submitted perhaps
you have from your email box
representative Oregon uh for bringing
the the testimony yeah I appreciate that
the uh we have been checking the online
sign ups because we've had some from our
last build
um
so thank you and a couple of typos
prepped into the file I think sometimes
you I think sometimes they like the bits
rearrange themselves after you think
you're done with it but nasty things
anyway
and um somebody didn't say much about on
the bill which is what it actually
what it actually does it makes one
simple there's about
there's about 30 different days weeks
and months
which are um
which are mentioned in RSA
rsa4 they started I think with RSA 13 a
and go through DD and this would add
another one so this doesn't uh cost
anything it's just uh instructs the
governor to issue a proclamation every
year in advance of her birthday which is
a
January 24th her 113th birthday is
coming up in a few days
and um
and does feel very much like she's still
alive even though she passed away and at
the age of 100 in 2010 so that's what
the bill does we have a lot of other
weeks months and days and this just adds
one more of the list and I think she
very much deserves it she's one of the
greatest people the most influential
people ever to come out of New Hampshire
um
and uh
so I guess I started with my second
paragraph actually she's a rebel with
the cause
okay you don't want me to read please
don't know read
it yeah
borrow check in this community and
everybody can read okay cool
and um
yeah so she's
famous for a number of things um when
you're 100 years old especially a
distinguished a life you see is she did
lots of things but she's most famous for
uh
marching across the country she started
on New Year's Day in 1999 at the Rose
Bowl Parade in Pasadena California March
uh 3 200 miles uh mostly on foot she had
to do uh some of it by by cross country
ski because there was a snowstorm in
West Virginia and Virginia when she
arrived 14 months later and then um
so she uh
eventually uh made to the Capitol
um she was arrested there for joined a
group of 220 other people but all they
were doing was reading the Declaration
of Independence and she also
successfully uh lobbied
for uh more campaign Finance reform
because uh that was what that was what
her walk was about raising at wherements
that you know we need the people should
be choosing uh
so all the people should be choosing our
our elected leaders not just those with
the most money not just the corporations
um
and then
January 6 2023 I happened to attend uh a
zoom remembrance vigil which is about
all the events that followed the
election in 2020 and we all remember
those who have different opinions about
them but it was a pretty frightening and
hopeful
time and that became a nation night
webinar at first they had uh
so that was at 8 30 p.m on that Friday
night which 5 30 p.m the west coast is
around when the sun sets but anyway
after a speech by the Nationwide
president of the League of Women Voters
whose name I have here Virginia
Solomon then one of the local chapters
this was uh
in Alabama County which is uh as most
you probably know the east side of San
Francisco Bay the East Bay Area and the
first she spent most of her time about a
five minute March talking about how she
was inspired by uh
a woman from New Hampshire Doris granny
D haddock so she's not just a legend
here in New Hampshire but a legend
Nationwide and even worldwide so that's
uh another reason to remember her so uh
her presence is strong not just in
California or New Hampshire so she's
very much alive in our memories and the
passage of this bill will keep
your memory alive and uh
my written testimony does close with the
some remarks she made down whether you
want me to read them now or do you want
me
no thank you okay you can all uh you can
all read it now and it's available on
your Wikipedia article too but uh and I
I couldn't have said it as uh I couldn't
have said it as eloquently as as she did
she's probably
probably I think the greatest person
I've didn't get to know as well as I
should have but I I had the honor of
getting to know her uh you know very
late in her life and probably the
greatest person I've ever
I've ever I've ever met you know greater
even than President Obama or the Jazz
drummer Dizzy Gillespie um so I think
you know see and it's also proved a lot
just what you know
what just an ordinary citizen can do you
know she was just a uh an ordinary uh
well she wasn't just a granny she was
you know she was
she led a very long 100 year long life
and she was many things and then
last thing I was going to say like her
100th birthday party uh that was uh
she was about nine years old when women
got the right to vote so she was born in
1910 and that was passed in 1919 and she
very you know she wasn't just a simple
granny from Dublin she was a very you
know very candy uh for any candy show
woman you know very talented
entrepreneur you know very very good
politician so she
made sure that she was introduced by a
young woman I believe from in her
community but somewhere around who is
about the same who was about nine years
old the same age she was
um
the same way same way she was the same
way she was when we passed the women's
right to vote and that kind of reminded
me of how short life was how recent you
know historical events happened you know
we take the women's right to vote to
granted and lots of other rights but you
know
just within uh
granny D's lifetime which is longer than
most people but still not really a long
time in the larger schemes of things
women did not have the right to vote and
there are all kinds of other rights
um that were taken for granted today
which uh people didn't have back then or
even uh long into her lifetime so I urge
you to uh urge you to add add this to
the long list of other uh
other other things which the governor
proclaims every year I think it's uh
probably the most important of all those
20 proclamations so um
with that I closed my testimony and of
course if you have to take any questions
should anyone have any
so eloquent that you've answered all our
questions yeah oh well I hope so like
I'm surprised to hear that but you never
know anything can happen thanks a lot
okay
Olivia zinc
uh good afternoon my name is Olivia Zink
I'm the executive director of open
democracy and open democracy action
which is an organization a New Hampshire
organization that Granny D founded
um
and I I brought with me some materials
um some of the books that have been
written about granny D
um but I also just wanted to sort of
speak to a couple of things
um one
um this is a really important issue
um to just not only honor the woman her
hundred years of life
um there's there's some items in
um
this piece of legislation but also she
did work in Alaska with Native American
folks around nuclear weapons and nuclear
proliferation she did work to ensure
that there was a 101 going through uh
over to Keene she worked with the Mills
the mill women that she worked with
making shoes in Manchester she was born
in Laconia so she she really was a
remarkable woman for her hundred years I
was looking back through the state
archives at Keene State College that has
comments from Newt Gingrich and John
McCain and Warren Rudman about this
woman granny D so she not only touched
Democrats which was the party she
belonged to but she touched people
across the political Spectrum in her
work USA Today did declare her one of
the top 10 women of um so I have a link
to that if anyone's interested I first
met her after she walked across the
country
um
and she was really able to connect
issues that I cared about around safe
and clean drinking water
um to the issues of democracy and why it
mattered to vote and why it mattered to
be paying attention and be civically
involved and I think she inspired women
across the country
she uh stood in for a woman who was a
mermaid in an amusement park so that
that woman could register to vote so
there's lots of different things that
Granny D did that were really historic
and also just really remarkable
she always wore a feather in her hat
um
and was sort of known by this hat that
she wore on her head if you've if you
met with her walked with her
and I I wanted to share a remark by her
family when she decided at age 88 to
start her walk 10 miles a day across the
country her family said Nana are you
sure about this do we need to to take
you to the doctors are you okay and she
was so strong in her conviction she
really wanted to walk 10 miles a day for
this cause and and really talk to others
about that I do have testimony from a
Peterborough resident who was unable to
be here today due to a health concern so
I will share John windham's testimony
and the other thing I wanted to say is
that I just got word the governor signed
this year's Proclamation so this year's
Proclamation was signed by Chris sununu
for the granny D Day on June in two
weeks but I I will say that I know that
this that and anyone can request a
proclamation but Ruth and and many of
the women who knew granny D Have and
Have Been requesting this Proclamation
are getting older they're now 90 years
old too they knew her 20 years ago and I
think that as somebody who has passed
away
um
you know and and who would have been
112. the number of people they actually
touched gets less and less each year so
it's important to pass these pieces of
legislation because not always will
there be somebody who remembers her or
knew her
um
to request a proclamation in the future
and with that I'm happy to take any
questions
are there any questions
representative
thank you um
I mean you're mentioning the people that
knew her
um
have passed but there are memorials for
people who are you know died much longer
ago and people considered important I
would hope somebody else would take up
that cause
um
I'm wondering if having a you know an
active group trying to promote this on a
regular basis rather than something
sitting in statute might be more
effective I mean is there a group of
people that you know beyond these people
who asked for a proclamation and
organize any kind of events in the state
to
um you know commemorate her and and uh
and and you know keep her memory alive
I'm wondering
yeah I think there's a
there's
um want to keep her memory alive and I
invite you to join us on January 24th at
7 pm uh to hear from people who knew
granny D
um and
um want to kind of Honor her so there is
a zoom presentation that I can send you
a link to if you're interested
um but I think that when I first got
involved with uh open democracy and
Granny D A lot of people knew her worked
with her and I will just say in the last
10 years many of those people I worked
with have passed away and and the people
who she walked across the country 20
years ago so somebody said to me oh she
walked across the country before I was
alive and so I do think that it is
important
um
to remember and and honor folks but
having it in Statue where the governor
issues this automatically instead of
having it be requested each year
um does show that she's a prominent
woman
um I I failed to mention in my testimony
that Sharon Carson sponsored a bill um
that was 24-nothing for this same bill
it was Senate Bill
537 and I will encourage you to talk to
Senator Sharon Carson somebody who knew
granny D and and honored her
um if you have if you happen to to see
her in the hallway
thank you representative baber
thank you for being here
um my question oh thank you madam chair
my question is did you know her number
one and number two what I see she's from
Dublin what what kind of events do they
have annually for her
thank you
um so yeah she she was born in Laconia
she worked in the mills in Manchester
but the later part of her life was in
Dublin
um each year we do a granny deed Day
event on her birthday a celebration
um and it used to be at the executive
council chambers here at the State House
when she was still alive so her 100th
birthday was celebrated here at the
State House when when she was with us
um the Dublin
um there is a granny D Memorial walk
every summer from Dublin or in the
greater Monadnock area to celebrate her
life and there are also archives
um at the Dublin historical society and
the Dublin Library there is a a little
bit of information about about her life
actually just talked to the librarian in
Dublin who was going to try to get me
some information and then the Keene
State College Mason Library she is her
collection is there as well so if you
actually wanted to see lots of things
about her I would encourage you to go to
the Mason Library at Keene State or if
you're ever in Keene to stop in and read
about her or see any of the the living
archives
and there's also documentaries made so
HBO did a documentary about her life as
well
thank you
I'd like to mention to the committee
that there are in fact 17 Pro and one
opposed testimony on the on the website
for your four and four of those people
have written uh specific testimony
rather than just indicating support
any other questions comment
thank you very much
yes excuse me representable to get a
question
well
um
okay thank you Miss Inc
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill 140.
all right seeing none I'll close the
public hearing
and
without objection we can go into
executive session
representative Broder you have a motion
yes Madam chair I vote I make a motion
to itl house bill 140.
is there a second
okay representative a bear seconds okay
did you speak to your motion
yes
there is no doubt that Community was an
important person in New Hampshire
history or in the history of democracy
and although
um
the house bill is clear
as a committee
we have not supported these kinds of
legislation because
it
just to trigger
a proclamation every year
doesn't really bring is not a meaningful
nor is it a
appropriate way to
honor such a person
if they want if you you know I think
that the towns that she lived in having
a having festivals having
um
organizations like Urban democracy that
continue to do her work is important but
I don't
believe that this committee can has
um
I know I'm sorry I'm getting distracted
by all this paper
excuse me
um I don't believe this bill
is going to be helpful to prolong her
name which I think is what you're trying
to do
thank you representative beard you wish
to speak to your second
does anyone else wish to say something
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair
well I'm sure I'm not the only one on
the committee but I'm one of the members
of the committee I certainly who did
know Granny D and interacted with her a
number of times over the years of her
most public uh
Mission if you will and I heard her
speak she was a powerful orator I I
campaigned with her on a number of
occasions and I was there on her 100th
birthday so uh I defer to no one in my
respect for her significant
accomplishments I think in in in in a
way it is more meaningful that uh that
the governor is voluntarily uh
proclaiming her birthday
um every
um every January
um and and I think as long as uh as long
as she's still a present figure in many
respects
um that uh that that aspect is
appropriate
um and and there are countless people in
this state as well as hundreds of
thousands in this country uh who have
had lives of Fame and accomplishment uh
and
um and the history books record them to
various degrees uh so I think it's more
important to have a voluntary thing than
to put it in the stature to be buried
because when
when she's forgotten by most people
because her her that era has passed uh
then then only the history books will
record her uh in the meantime she has a
limiting Memorial and that's the uh the
uh organization that Miss zinc referred
to so I'm I'm going to reluctantly vote
Yes on this Ito motion because I think
we should keep her alive with something
alive and not something that's a dead
letter of sorts in the stature book
Thank
any other representative like us yeah
um what I would have said is uh already
mostly been said by the uh previous two
speakers I agree completely the only
thing I would add is you know I applaud
um the people that are organizing uh the
events that are going on and I think
that's both the appropriate and the
effective way of uh of keeping her
memory alive and I think that's great
thank you thank you anyone else have a
comment representative Gould
I just wanted to quickly say thank you
Olivia for all you've done I never met
her she was one of my heroes as soon as
I learned about her I can't imagine
she's ever going to be forgotten
because you keep her alive
representative
thank you madam chair
um I'm on of an age that I was
privileged to meet granny D and uh I'll
call to the attention of committee
members that there is a lady who does a
reenactment of her walk that is often
sponsored by the humanities Council in
New Hampshire if you get a chance to see
that show I think you would enjoy it she
really captures the spirit of her
movement
thank you okay anyone else
all right seeing none
uh we'll call the question the mo the
motion is inexping to legislate on House
Bill 140 made by representative Brodus
second by representative a bear and the
clerk and call the rule
I'm now taking vote role for house bill
140.
representative Simon yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Bailey yes
representative sentosaso yes
representative true yes
representative Aver yes representative
Gerhard yes
representative stairway yes
representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes
representative schuett yes
representative O'Brien
yes representative shurtleff yes
representative Davis
yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould
yes representative rung
yes Madam chair yeah
19.
yays zero Nays
19 years the motion passes is there any
objection to consent
okay seeing none we'll put this one on
consent also
we have a few minutes before our next
hearing which starts at 2 30.
okay
welcome back to Edna
we're here on public hearing on House
Bill 180. and I call the prime sponsor
representative Horrigan
if anyone else has written testimony
feel free to pass it around now so we're
only Disturbed once
thank you very much Madam chair so I
continue to be and I don't think I said
this at the first time representative
Timothy Horrigan that represents
Stratford County District 10 with the
towns of Durham
um
Durham is also although this is a
tradition that fell by the wayside a few
years ago the home of the Leif Ericsson
Day celebration which is always on the
Sunday before uh which I guess the
second Monday in October which is
currently a fish and the reason they
picked that day was because they have no
idea what day late Erickson arrived and
uh in Greenland but they know it was
before Columbus that's why they picked
that Sunday but anyway
um this is a pretty simple build the
issues behind it are complicated it
changes the name of the existing
mid-october holiday held on the second
Monday in October from Columbus Day to
indigenous people stay in this um
Monday's been celebrated unofficially
and even officially in many communities
and school districts as indigenous
people stay for a number of years in
fact I think it's become a more
significant celebration than Columbus
Day and we can continue to be a
highlight of the yearless calendar what
happens uh you know this year to HP 180
and I certainly hope you'll pass it as
is I think the time has come for it um
and speaking just for myself that's my
goal to rename the mid-october holidays
I'm not uh
I want to continue having a holiday on
the second Monday in October and I want
to be officially named after the native
peoples of North America and also if if
possible I want to be named after
Christopher not to be named after
Christopher Columbus and there's
probably a lot of
reasons why they established the
Columbus holiday but um I think
I think they're not valid anymore he
wasn't even um
yeah didn't didn't become an official
holidays in 1971 so I think the right
thing to do now in 2023 is uh
keep that same holiday but make us a
Columbus Day and of course to go back to
Columbus we were probably all well I
guess I don't know what goes on great
schools in or recent years but at least
if you're my age we all learned in grade
school that he discovered American
1492 but of course the millions of
people living in the Americas in 1492
were already well aware that America
existed of
and um
Columbus himself
Columbus himself was not the first
European to travel to North America and
actually it turns out he wasn't even
really surprised to find land where he
he found it so he had a pretty accurate
idea of how wide the Atlantic Ocean was
he had a pretty good idea that land
would be where he found it and that was
for various reasons including the fact
that many Europeans had
been there before and he's presumably
been talking for example the Portuguese
fishermen who were fishing off the grant
Banks and so forth so
um best known example I mentioned Leif
Erickson Leif Erickson was one of the
first uh one of the
uh maybe wasn't the first one but here's
one of the Scandinavians who established
a very well documented colony in
Greenland which survived for 500 years
beginning in the mid 900s and it uh
ended uh well there's conflict in
Warfare and bad things to happen along
the way but it was relatively relatively
peaceful not really all that long before
Columbus's day when the dissented the
original Colonnade is
they served reverse migrated back to
Scandinavia in the mid-1400s and that
was because of uh the climate had become
cooler the economy in Europe had
collapsed and there's anyway there's
more up they decided there's more
opportunity for them to go back to their
ancestors Homeland rather than the stay
where they were and they were probably
Scandinavians and uh in other parts of
North America and actually
one of the first accounts is a I'm of
Irish ancestors one of the first
accounts was a group of Irish monks led
by Saint Brenton so they that was uh
that was like a couple hundred years at
least before uh late barrickson's time
so we were not Columbus was certainly
not the first person to cross the
Atlanta across the Atlantic and also
people came to North America from uh
from Asia Russians came there uh
uh Chinese uh probably came to uh
Central America so the Polynesians uh
you know came from came from Hawaii
which is now one of the United States
actually so
and um so I mentioned that Columbus
wasn't Italian he's from the Republic of
Genoa which is a small country which uh
cease to exist three and a half
centuries after Columbus's time when it
was basically split up between France
and France and Italy and Genoa is now a
Italian city but um he spoke a language
called ligurian which people still speak
but it's more closely related to the
French and Italian he's been most of his
life in Spain and Portugal so he was not
actually Italian
really not really Italian at all he was
a he was Spanish but that's um
and he certainly never came to the
United States the closest he came was
the Bahamas so I think um
so I think it's time to rename the
Columbus Day holiday and we should have
indigenous people's day
on that Monday in October when it is
currently being celebrated and when
we've had a mid-fall holiday for many
many years so that's uh
that's that's my proposal this is not
the first uh go around for this but I
think now is the time to finally pass it
so I guess I'd be happy to take any
questions although thank you
representative are there any questions
represent Bailey
have you considered I mean as you say
it's been around a few times yeah have
you considered splitting it into two
parts ending the holiday
versus renaming the holiday uh well
that's up to you that's not what I
personally had in mind but you know the
committee's bill you can
you can do what you you can do what you
want with it and I'll Reserve judgment
on in advance and whether or not I'll if
you vote for any amended version you
might come I think this is a I mean I
think this is a good bill has been
vetted uh through several trips to the
legislative process and I think it's
ready to go as is but if the committee
disagrees well that's that's up to you
that's your call thank you thank you
other questions
all right thank you very much excuse me
representative O'Brien please that's
quiet all right thank you madam chair
representative uh one of my concerns
just to make sure but I would like to
have it I know your answer I think but
document it into the testimony this will
have no effect on any existing treaty
which we do not have or anything else
like that no other move in the future by
any of the Native American tribes
um I can't really
they can't really speak for any Native
American tribes now or in the future
there are some uh local people
local native people who are here they'll
speak for themselves but I think even
they can't predict what's going to
happen in the future so that's uh but
the goal of this bill is just to rename
the holiday which is in any case
uh just like we're both Irish ancestry
both just like St Patrick's Day is a
popular celebration for even people of
non-irish ancestry this has become a
popular celebration even for people of
non-native ancestry so I'm not sure what
else more to say about it but
foreign
any other questions
all right thank you very much
representative Petrino
thank you madam
chair and members of the committee
I'm representative Peter Petrino I
represent Hillsborough 43 the town of
Milford
I wasn't planning on testifying today
but after reading a tweet this morning
that said and I quote
Representatives saying that they don't
support indigenous people's day
because it is damaging to their Italian
heritage
that is exactly what white supremacy is
all about
that was very unfortunate
and I have reason to believe that it was
directed at me
I could not let it go unanswered
so here I am
I think most of you would agree that
Massachusetts is one of the most
Progressive most liberal states in the
country
yet legislation for indigenous people's
day in Massachusetts has continued to
fail
why
because the current Speaker of the House
and the last two speakers of the house
are Italian-American and they have
fiercely defended their heritage
so how is it that Italian-American
Heritage in Columbus Day became
associated
at a time when Italians were referred to
as docked skinned whites
who was short with large noses and
greasy dark curly hair
papists garlic eaters who don't belong
in this country and need to go back to
where they came from
in fact
it was President Benjamin Harrison who
first recognized Columbus Day in 1892 as
a way to show support for Italian
immigrants after a mass lynching of
Italians in New Orleans
the year before
now of course times have changed and
many no longer recognize Columbus as the
hero he once was proclaimed
and you will hear
testimony that Columbus was Italian
he wasn't Italian he discovered America
he didn't discover America
all of that is immaterial to me
let me make it perfectly clear that I do
not care if we remove the name Columbus
from the day
what I really care about
is not losing the long-standing
recognition of Italian Americans on that
day
now Colorado
has continued the tradition of
recognizing Italian-American
by changing the name Columbus Day to
Cabrini day in honor of Mother Frances
Xavier Cabrini an Italian immigrant
who became an American citizen
in her life's mission was to work with
immigrants what a tremendous honor
in a person to admire
especially as we witnessed the plight of
today's immigrants
likewise
it is appropriate that we aren't Native
Americans we already have days of
recognition in November and in August
and I'd be happy to see those days
codified as holidays
now since I've been here in the house we
legislators have been greeted with
bagpipes on St Patrick's Day
beautiful native dancing and again
bagpipes on Scottish Totten day
Cinco de Mayo was acknowledged during
unanimous consent we have heard speeches
delivered in French Spanish polish
I and other Italian Americans are no
less proud of our heritage
we should not be divisive and pit one
ethnic group against another
there is no hope for Humanity if we do
not recognize support and celebrate our
common Humanity
thank you very much for listening to my
testimony and I'd be happy to take any
questions
thank you madam chair um representative
thank you for taking my question I'm
going to go back into your
Italian-American you know linear chair
but have you ever heard of the term
cyclone benzetti and if you have not
that's fair but I do urge members of the
committee to look up that particular
Massachusetts case it may have some
additional information to them on it but
I wonder if you ever heard of those two
gentlemen yes I have I was born and
raised in the North End of Boston
Boston's Little Italy I still have
family that lives down there I'm very
proud of my Heritage the North End of
Boston was the home of the Saco and
venzetti defense committee and it was
from there on Hannibal Street at
langone's funeral home where they had
their their funeral
foreign
follow-up thank you more into it ties
into Columbus Day I see I was led to
believe that that may have been one of
the appeasements they were executed
wrongfully so they received pardons from
the Massachusetts governor but in
relation to uh Columbus Day that's
correct and when the bigots
um called insult to Italian Americans
Italians always were able to say you
know uh if it wasn't for an Italian
um this country would not have been
discovered and you wouldn't be here
today I mean that was always the retort
when faced with that kind of
discrimination now again I understand
that times have changed and we no longer
look at Columbus as the hero we once did
but a hundred years ago 50 years ago 20
years ago when I was a boy he was looked
upon as a hero and Italians always said
hey look if it wasn't for one of our own
this country wouldn't be here and you
bigots who was saying we don't belong
well listen you wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for one of ours
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you
hey
Fred and I have have to leave but
representative leckis will take over and
I call Representative sophakitus
foreign
for the record my name is Catherine
sofikidis this is my fourth term as a
legislator I'm from Nashville award
seven which is called Crown Hill if you
are familiar with that area of Nashua I
am here today to talk
uh in support of House Bill 180 which is
probably no surprise to anybody here I
was born in the territory of Alaska
before statehood
I I want to be brutally brutally Frank
with all of you here
there is not one person of color on this
committee not one
and racism
matters and I want to give you some
terms that I want you to look up because
the last time around with this I heard
so much ridiculous things out of this
committee
so the first word I want you to look up
is to decolonialize now I realize that
we are right here
in the heart of colonial America
but
the rest of the country
understands what you the colonialists
have done
and the colonialist came and now you say
because we're here that the country
started
well nothing could be further from the
truth
the people were already here they were
here they were living wonderful lives
and why don't you see Indians here
Indians because Columbus thought he
found Indians because he found a way
to the Silk Road he didn't they're not
indians they're Native Americans and
my oldest brother who's adopted is a
clinket Indian
I grew up among indigenous people in
Alaska and furthermore in Guam where my
father was the United States Attorney
for President Nixon
I grew up a white minority and I'm
totally totally comfortable with it
so
I married I married a Greek
when I was 20.
the most ethnic Greek you could ever
imagine and it wasn't American citizen
until after we were married but
um
there's got to be a way for all of this
ethnic people to understand that the
humanity of the world demands that
reconciliation
with our history needs to happen
and even our brothers and sisters to the
North in Canada who are wrestling with
this same issue have understand
understood in the last few years and
they have Country-Wide past
reconciliation now why why I heard
questions about why does it have to be a
state law
because
people come to the the State House
for remedy for remedy they come our
constituents come here for remedy from
the government the government of Crim
did genocide I want you to look up
um
the residential school program the
residential school program where the
children were taken away from their
families so that they could break the
culture of the indigenous people
that they have committed atrocities that
went over hundreds of years I want you
to look up the Wounded Knee Massacre I
want you to look up the Sand River
Massacre and I want you to know that we
have just passed a huge Memorial to the
Wounded Knee Massacre where children
young adults
take their horses the last week of
December and they ride
from Standing Rock reservation
to the site of the Wounded Knee Massacre
every year the last week of December and
if you can imagine what that weather is
like now why is it important here for
New Hampshire because this is where it
started
we need to understand that there was
people there was a
civilization a rich Dynamic civilization
in this state
before
colonization
and we are taught Lies We are taught
so many things that are not true about
the past of this country and it is time
it is time the internet has been a great
equalizer and we can understand
that we all have to live together and
part of that living together is to
reconcile
and to understand and we cannot do that
without legislation and so I am not
saying anything about any
ethnic group I'm about as ethnic Greek
as you can be
so I love
ethnicity I love it but that ethnicity
also includes our indigenous people
thank you
thank you um any questions
to the speaker
uh representative O'Brien thank you Mr
chair uh representative uh coming from
where I do in the great city of Nashua
uh Nashua did by the vote of the board
of aldermen did change the name to both
Columbus Day and Indigenous people today
am I correct in that yes thank you
any other questions
see none thank you thank you
okay I'd like to call
um if I'm reading the name correctly uh
Fawn Gaudet
if I got that wrong reading this please
correct me
hi hello everyone my name is Fawn Cadet
thank you for having me
my name is Fon Cadet and I live in New
Hampshire I am a descendant of a proud
of the Senate of the blackfeet nation
that's in Montana I am someone that has
grown up in New Hampshire but also has
lived on a reservation it wasn't mine we
didn't have a dormitory there when I
wanted to go to college so I found one
on the Navajo res
so while being a descendant of the
blackfeet nation and mixed tribes I also
very clearly mixed so I also got the
experience like Catherine of being the
minority amongst many full-blood Natives
and it was a wonderful experience and in
my family I'm
um also have being a bit more mixed that
experience so I've I've been able to un
you know relate and live through many
things and have that experience with my
family and people on a reservations many
reservations my family I have family on
many reservations different different
tribes so I can I can speak to what the
effect of white supremacy can be in many
Avenues having experienced you know
different aspects of it why I feel like
I'm requesting Columbus Day to be
changed indigenous peoples in New
Hampshire because of the strong pride in
my ancestry when I grew up here as a
child I was keenly aware of the
injustices committed to Native Americans
and then having lived on a reservation
and through my family absolutely aware
of racism hardships I have family
members that were in residential schools
I have family members that have lived in
reservations I've lived on a reservation
and
some people don't even have running
water still electricity and that is a
way of life for people
but there's many people still have
overcome these hardships to thrive
but this is what's important I am keenly
aware of the injustices committed
against Native Americans this being our
nation first this nation was already
inhabited with indigenous peoples and we
are still here
this land this this right here was is
native land I'm not saying was it still
is because we never succeeded this land
at all
this was overcome
so before Columbus era there were
millions of indigenous peoples in North
America Central America and South
America the wabanaki known as the people
of the Dawn lived in New Hampshire long
before the colonists survived indigenous
peoples here thrived in harmony with
gadakana which means world for wabanaki
their culture was rich with tradition
honor and respect for the people land
and Wildlife
I want to say that the Kawasaki band of
the Penacook Abenaki are the local
people in this area who also support the
change and have worked for years to help
make this happen
for me Columbus Day is not a day of joy
it is a day of mourning and I should say
nationally to indigenous peoples it is a
day of mourning
during this period terrorism occurred to
indigenous peoples they were massacred
rape enslaved tortured and genocide
occurred now I've read many things that
said up to 124 million in indigenous
peoples were here before this era
occurred I've also read it's down to 120
million but after that period when all
this occurred it went down to as low as
6 million indigenous peoples there are
some tribes that they're not even sure
exists now
that is horrific
changing this holiday to indigenous
people say offers honor and respect to
our people
as Columbus say this only marks a false
representation of what happened to the
past and that is white supremacy if we
do not teach the truth of what happened
we are allowing this awful awful
horrible horrible things that happen
that could be repeated again you have to
teach the truth so you do not repeat it
we have to teach children we have to
teach our society to tell the truth to
honor and respect people by changing the
name to indigenous people say you will
offer truth it is a chance for a New
Hampshire residents indigenous and
non-indigenous
to honor those who came before them and
respect the indigenous peoples here to
survive to carry on the rich native
traditions for our future Seven
Generations please pass HP 180 renaming
Columbus Day indigenous people say in
New Hampshire I also want to say that
this is a national movement that has
gotten over 130 towns in 12 states are
already selling celebrating indigenous
people's day in New Hampshire we believe
we have 20 I have to get the count it
might be 22 towns yep 22 towns and
municipalities that celebrate it we just
recently got Plymouth it's moving
forward
um schools are adopting it colleges are
adopting it so I really hope that this
is the time that we can make this happen
in New Hampshire
and I'm happy to take any questions
thank you any questions for the speaker
representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman
seems like maybe you are speaking from a
written document
yes which I pretty much have memorized
I've I've done this a while uh could you
possibly provide that to the committee
do you have it
also I sent it to you via email and
there was some glitch via the emails as
well I think
just so you know
one of our emails got bounced back so
I hope that can be worked out thank you
any other questions
I appreciate your time thank you so much
I'd like to call uh Sarah Smith
good afternoon thank you my name is
Sarah Smith thank you for taking my
testimony I live um here uh nearby in
Suncook which is on unseated uh
territory of the Abenaki people
um
and I'm here to speak about how uh I
don't believe that
Columbus was a hero I'm a I'm a retired
teacher I spent a lot of time seeing how
uh these kind of holidays are are taught
in schools
um and usually it's it's some kind of
mythoh heroic kind of idea that's put
forth
um I feel that Columbus himself was
um a brutal person
um
uh the um
and they're so there there are a number
of reasons I want to and I'm going to
focus mostly on what I've learned about
Columbus
um
and uh first of all he didn't really
discover America
um he never set foot on what we consider
North America at all
he spent his time in the Caribbean he
spent a little bit of time in South
America never set foot on
um North America
and uh
and in his own journals Columbus recites
how an easily Native Americans native
people could be enslaved and exploited
and he quickly proceeded to do so
one of the things that I found that
really troubled me was the amount of uh
in enslavement that he uh
put forth um
uh he um
I'll start with some of this some of the
the brutality that he's um known for
um
see so
I'm looking at some notes here if I'm
not trying to read them all
um but uh
there's just a few a few little stories
here that uh that
that really stuck stuck out at me
um
that
uh he uh
at one point
um on Saint Croix I come spread
um according to his own count kept an
indigenous woman he captured whom
Columbus quote gave to him then brutally
raped her
another uh instance of his brutality the
punishment for an indigenous person
who was age 14 or older failing to pay a
hawks Bell or casabella
worth of gold dust every six months was
cutting off the hands of those without
tokens often leading them to bleed to
death
um
so this and there's numerous stories of
his dismemberment practices
um this which apparently was one of the
things that he thought was a way to
control the population
um
and
it's interesting because the uh doctrine
of Discovery was put forth to
um
allow that the enslavement of
non-christians
and so he had an economic interest in
enslavement of this these uh natives
that he met and so he was not eager to
baptize them
so this he Not only was not really doing
the purpose of of uh christianizing the
lands but he was actually
um avoiding that uh
and at one point he was recalled as
Governor by
uh Queen Isabella and King Ferdinand
because of the brutality of his regime
that they're not particularly nice
people themselves
yet here they are calling this person
too brutal to govern
um
so that this um
there's a really interesting uh example
of the enslavement that he did he one
point he rounded up about 1500 of the
the airlocks who are the native people
and
um
and they and about 500 of the strongest
were shipped to Spain as slaves
and about 200 of those who died in route
so there was a constant
um
death as well as enslavement in his um
and at one point
he was reported that he punished a man
found guilty of stealing corn
by having his ears and nose cut off
and then selling them
are you reading your testimony which you
provided to us
I'm sorry are you reading the testimony
that you provided to us if so if you
could just summarize oh hi I'm
surprising it I am summarizing I just
noticed you indicated some examples this
these are this is a lot more involved
here
um so uh
uh
so I just wanted to point out that that
I'll summarize it this way
either he was a brutal man
who was not a hero
and and as a teacher I can't imagine
teaching the truth about him
uh so that this is the part that
troubles me there's no heroic part that
of this story that can be taught to kids
um and so it should be
he should be
um relegated to the minor part of
history of that he really played and and
let's I and I'll yield to the indigenous
people here to explain why indigenous
people day is much greater use of our
educational time
thank you
um does anyone have I don't know if
you'll take questions does anyone have
any questions
you've seen none thank you you're going
to provide the original
um have you provided that you've passed
around the written testimony yes
okay thank you no
okay I'm gonna have a problem reading
this it's Sebastian
when I I can't read what was what was
that when
point oh Fuentes okay thank you thank
you yep sorry
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee for allowing me
to speak to you today uh indigenous
people today and its recognition will
help correct uh a white wash notion that
Christopher Columbus was Italian uh
let's be honest you know the Republic of
Italy was informed then he came from he
traveled the Seas from the Republic of
uh Genoa so I'm here to recognize that
the contributions of indigenous people
uh to this nation
you know but also to speak about the
need to recognize to recognize the
existence of indigenous peoples all
around the Americas uh 54 million people
live currently to this day in North
Central and South America uh I'm on for
it's unfortunate that representative
Petrino left because I was the one that
made that tweet this morning uh and
definitely was indirected to him uh it
was directly mostly to other
representatives to make the comment that
they couldn't support indigenous people
they because they were members of the
Knights of Columbus so that was going to
be offenses to them so that's the reason
why I posted that tweet so he felt there
was an attack doing my apologies but it
wasn't directed to him as well so uh you
know I was born and raised in Lima Peru
uh in Peru as you know it's a country in
South America you know Neighbor In the
End these mountains beautiful mountains
where we have about 5.9 million
indigenous people living in this in that
country right now uh you know how do I
know the struggles of the indigenous
Community because of my ancestors and
how I know this you know my parents my
dad is a third generation descendant of
uh the shaman a shaman Community up in
the north part of Peru in kahama
um how I know this I didn't pay 49.99
for ancestry.com DNA kit I actually
learned this from the uh tales and
histories that my family has passed to
us to generations and generations so uh
that's what I know it he was uh they
were a people's healer he was the
community doctor
so as I sit in front of you today to
Advocate to recognize the existence and
the importance of the Legacy uh not just
only of the abenaki's Cherokees Lenape
Iroquois choctaws and Apache and many
more indigenous communities in the US
I'm also here to ask you to please
recognize that this uh this is also an
issue that crosses borders borders that
were created by
after the fact because the Indians
communities didn't have any borders you
know indigenous people who are all
around the Americas tainos of Puerto
Rico Mayans of Guatemala
uravas of Colombia I made us quechos
matses shipos Juan Cas now wattles and
guaranis all down in South America as
well and Central America
and there's only 1500 other communities
indigenous communities
the thrive
but I don't have the time to mention all
of them
but I but I have the urgency to to
recognize them
indigenous people want to celebrate and
remember their existence I have to have
a little bit of trouble understanding
what is the Italian Community trying to
celebrate
so if you allow me today I want to just
uh kind of share some thoughts with uh
with you in in my own indigenous
language of my community
a what that means is the strength of the
mountains be to you all the strength of
the Arab with you all
healings to your hearts
blessings to you and your loved ones and
one love for all thank you
any questions for the speaker
okay thank you thank you so much
I'd like to call Sarah Robinson
hello
uh thank you Mr chair from the committee
uh for the opportunity to speak to you
today my name is Sarah Robinson and I am
the education Justice campaign director
for Granite State progress a multi-issue
advocacy organization working on issues
of immediate state and local concern
indigenous people's day is already
becoming the norm for our state the
municipality that we are currently
sitting in acknowledges indigenous
people's day a decision that followed a
long line of other communities that had
already made this switch to honoring the
people who lived on this land for
centuries before colonization took place
sending HB 180 to the full legislature
with a recommendation of ought to pass
would be a step in the right direction
for New Hampshire a state that values
its Rich history as well as the people
who call this unique State home
this is not an attempt to erase
um
pardon me I lost my spot
um this is not an attempt to erase the
value of other communities but a wide
step forward in repairing the harm
levied against our indigenous brothers
and sisters who continue to call New
Hampshire their home
aren't there historical and current
contributions to our land culture and
history worth our reverence
shouldn't our history and Community
reflect the experiences and stories of
all of us our local indigenous
communities bands of the Abenaki people
also known as the people of the donland
continue to offer us their culture
stories art and ways of knowing at their
own expense and for the sake of their
own preservation
their history and place of belonging in
this great state all the more
significant because of the great odds
and barriers they have overcome to
preserve it deserve this long withheld
recognition
please vote in favor of HB 180 with an
ought to pass recommendation thank you
very much I can provide my testimony
electronically to you all do so yeah and
I'm happy to answer any questions you
might any questions for the speaker
okay thank you for the opportunity
and I'd like to call I believe it's Paul
and Denise poulette
okay a little hard to read the Twitter
the printing
apologize for Butchery names I'm both
trying to read uh Printing and then uh
and get it pronounced correctly so no
worries no why Anita Baker
IES
Hello friends my name is Denise puglio
I'm the head female speaker and this is
Paul puleo the head male speaker in
Chief of the Kawasaki band of the
Penacook abnaki people we come to you
today from our ancient Penacook Village
of odinaku and nipi which translates to
the Village of the narrowing of waters
now known as Alton New Hampshire
we've heard quite a bit of testimony and
it's all a very positive obviously we're
here to ask for the passage of HB 180
um
a lot of this history you know we could
rehash it again you have a written
testimony
we we saw this as a Grassroots movement
initially because various religious
groups
were trying to uh to deal with papal
decrees of the age of Discovery
especially in the 1400s
a lot of these papal Bulls became the
basis for taking land away from
indigenous peoples in the new world as
they said to divide it up between the
princes and and princesses of
Christianity as they were fighting
between the Royals of Europe
unfortunately
um a lot of harm was done these papal
bulls actually became the basis for a
lot of our federal laws which Justified
taking land especially in the 18 early
1800s when the Supreme Court in Jackson
and others argued about these issues and
eventually it it resulted in the
codification that it was righteous and
just as Christians to take the land away
from indigenous people after all we were
not civilized or considered part of
humanity
there's so much to be said about
Columbus
he was a genoan
Italy wasn't actually a country until
1861.
he may have been a mercenary he was
definitely a slaver by the time he
figured out that there was great
Enterprise and slavery because there
really was no gold in the Caribbean of
any value the Royals were always looking
for gold and silver as part of their
Treasury
to finance some of the stuff that
Columbus did
they took the land from the Jewish
communities just like they did from the
Moors you know the Muslim communities of
Europe took their lands and their
property to fund all the exploration for
the Christian world
so there was an intersection of cultures
it was not just indigenous peoples of
America that were impacted their other
religious face of Europe that were
impacted very severely by these kings
and queens
is without any doubt that he started the
global Atlantic slave trade it's well
documented his atrocities are well
documented his amusements with
brutalizing people were well documented
and he never really did find North
America
I'm 75 years old and I was brought up in
a school system where all we sang was in
1492 Columbus sailed the ocean blue and
he discovered America
it was a lie let's be honest about it it
was a lie in the beginning and it's
still perpetuated
we've always been trying to re-educate
and we're not saying we're changing
history we're not woke we're not trying
to revise history we just want everybody
to know there's another deep rich
inherited history that we have to come
to acknowledge We inherited this history
we don't have to apologize for it we
know that things weren't right we know
things that the papal decrees created
were not right
religious groups Many religious
religious groups were the first people
that worked with us to re
introduce the idea of indigenous
people's day and some of the church
groups that we work with wrote letters
to the pope saying that the papal Bulls
the 1400s have to be rescinded and
another papal statement come from
Vatican saying we repudiate the actions
of those popes in the past it hasn't
come to be so everything is now more or
less a Grassroots movement things have
been codified in federal law that
granted the use in stealing of land and
New England was the epicent of it let's
be candid this is where it all started
and it spread Westward from here
the abnacky Penacook in particular which
were occupying this whole Merrimack
River Valley system and a pescata as
well
have been here for thousands of years
our latest estimate is maybe as far back
as it's we know eight uh 12 800 years
and maybe 13 000 years so there are
people here well entrenched living here
living off the land and we'd like you to
recognize that fact
we realize also that there was a lot of
dissension about the dates we heard
several dates were recognized indigenous
people this day none of them really have
taken hold anywhere in the country you
know we hear about October dates
November dates not one of you could
actually tell me that date we then heard
people say well why don't we just use
the un's indigenous people's day when
they did all of the recognition of
indigenous peoples in the world
what countries oppose that the original
uh UK the original uh territories of the
United Kingdom
Canada Australia New Zealand and United
States all opposed indigenous peoples
rights initiatives that were initiated
by the U.N a date was established as our
October August 9th is indigenous
people's day but that does not satisfy
the needs of the indigenous communities
here in the Americas that is a worldwide
statement
in this country reach Administration has
fought against recognizing any U.N
resolutions
starting with the Bush Administration
and it goes back and forth I think Obama
tried to get it recognized he tried to
get indigenous people to stay you know
Clinton did as well they did
proclamations it's never taken hold
so when not to disparage all the
immigrants and I mean everybody thinks
the I you know first of all we had
Scotch French and English as first
immigrants here and then we had
um Irish we then we had uh polish and
and and God knows how many other ethnic
groups but it's unfortunate that certain
groups and and they were the Italians
are very right the Italians were very
highly persecuted as papists suavi not
even human in fact they almost put them
in the category of of uh indigenous
Africans that's how bad this was in
those days so I understand the
persecution they did just like many of
the African slaves were brought here
there was persecution and we have to
admit that's part of history but today
we don't really have to apologize for it
we just have to recognize it we call it
this inherited history
we'd like to just correct it it's in one
easy way without getting into the
physical responsibilities of a new
holiday
Columbus Day is pretty soft History Day
if you really think about it it's very
easy to change it without changing
budgets of towns or anything else all
you have to do is say Columbus has
historical footnote but indigenous
people were here well before that we are
doing deep research in the Vikings and
you'd be surprised what we're finding in
records that show that the Vikings were
here not just once up a way up in Nova
Scotia but in four locations along the
coast here what you also don't realize
the fishermen that were here off the
coast George's Banks the Gate of the
Gulf of Maine there were so many fishing
ships out here
looking for COD and why was it driven
like this the Vatican was seeking to
have more fish for Friday and dried fish
and who capitalized on that the
fishermen from the Iberian Peninsula
there were records that there were so
many fishing fleets off the coast well
before Columbus so what did Columbus do
he used he actually went to Iceland and
he talked with these the Portuguese
fishermen to figure out how to get here
he was not the Intrepid Explorer he used
other information from fishermen that
were already here off the coast from the
10th Century on he was 400 maybe 500
years late on discovering America people
are already getting Commerce here drying
Cod bringing back to Europe because he
had already depleted the fishing stocks
you got to read the Deep history of this
world it is really fascinating it is not
to be embarrassed we're not trying to
embarrass Italians or disparage them
it's just it's out of place today
let's get real there are indigenous
people here in the tens of millions all
over the place and it was a very robust
Society
and saving any questions
uh representative
thank you
so we've heard this bill several times
already and we don't seem to be making
any progress right we are okay it's not
here in this room right well I know I'm
just I'm sorry I'm just talking about
this world okay
because that's where the bill is
so what do you recommend what is it that
you really want
so we want to change Columbus to
indigenous people's day that's why we
put a bill forward asking for that we're
going to keep coming back and asking for
this I don't care how many times you
voted down we'll be back next year and
we'll be here asking for the same thing
in the meantime in the short period of
time since we've been bringing this bill
forward we've already turned over two
dozen towns in the state all right we've
already turned two school districts all
right and possibly three but I have to
verify that third one all right so the
change is already coming and it's just a
matter of the people in this room waking
up to recognize that the change is
already occurring around them
we really believe the Grassroots
movement will have enough gravity at
some point that this legislature will
not be able to ignore this any longer
like it was already said
the change the city in which this
legislature is currently being heard in
has already made the change
so it's now up to you
okay and there's no room for negotiation
as far as an amendment or no okay no
just want to know what are you going to
do celebrate Columbus Day uh you know
indigenous people stay the week before
and then celebrate Columbus Day the week
after that's in celebrating the
indigenous people who are originally
here and then celebrating our genocide a
week later so there is no compromise
okay follow up I just make a comment
that I'm asking you with good intentions
and I don't need sarcasm back it's not
sarcasm okay all right it sounds like it
though no it isn't um the reason why I
made that statement is a town here in
New Hampshire had made that change okay
and that was the response I gave to them
when I was asked my opinion about it
okay thank you you're welcome any other
questions
all right thank you and anyone else uh
who didn't sign up but would like to
speak on House Bill 180.
I'd see none I closed the public hearing
on House Bill 180. that's the last thing
we have for the day and we meet back
here tomorrow at 10 A.M
just when you come out of the elevator
okay you gotta turn left because it's
walls and so forth